*said the leprechaun*
Mark: Is this like the movie, The Cube?
Jack: Yeah
Wade: Yeah. Thats what I've been told but I've never seen it, sooo..
Wade: -only I've been told that... I dunno know.
Mark: The Cube is literally like a grid of cubes and each room can kill you
Wade: Yeah, basically that's it.
Jack: Control isn't crouch?
Mark: Wait what's crouch?
Bob: There is, isn't it?
Mark: I dunno what crouch is.
Jack: I'm not crouching.
Mark: I don't think there is a crouch. Wait-
Wade: I don't remember how to throw shoes.
Jack: Someone's floating through the air though when they do that.
Bob: [laughing] Somebody just threw their shoe!
Mark: [Jokingly] Well f*ck you man... F*ck you...
Jack: Take my piece of' sh*t shoe!
Mark: [moans halfheartedly and laughs]
Wade: HEY!
Wade: WHO THROWS A SHOE? Honestly!
Mark: [More laughs]
M: SHABOOSHKY!
B: There's a bunch right here on the floor
J: Ah, there we go.
[laughing and inaudible words]
M: Oh wait my shoe! Give me my shoe back.
B: Both of these directions suck. They're both red. Is that good or bad?
M: Uh huh.
B: Seems bad.
M: Should I try it?
W: Well, we're in a corner. Look at the mini map.
B: I know, that's what I'm saying.
B: The directions we have to go are either here--
M: OOOHH it's locked
W: Let's go this way!
M: Okay yeah that's right okay.
M: Alright who's first?
B: Oh.
M: I'll go!
J: I- I'll go- Aww.
W: Somebody throw it
B: uh...
W: um...
J: Is it safe?
M: Seems ok guys!
J: There's a demo--THERE'S A DEMON!!
B: OH MY GOD! OH JESUS!
M: WELL, that can't be that good!
J: Bye!!!
[Jack and Bob laughing]
M: You guys are assholes!
M: See, I'm fine here...
M: I'm not dead.
M: If you think I'm dead I'm not
W: Oh I thought Jack was in there that was Mark
M: Yeah I'm not dead guys.
B: Ohh my god he's just walking around!
M: You losers-
-You loser assholes.
J: It's okay!
M: See? And this room's good too!
M: You bunch of cowards think-
J: Nice!
M: -you can be all OoOoo!
B: AHH
B: Oh, it's you and me Mark.
J: Ok, how do we--
W: Alright Jack, we'll go our own way.
M: Oh that doesn't look good.
J: I'm goin this way! I'm not goin with any of y-
[Bob and Jack yelling]
M: AHHHHH! HA HE HE HU HUE
J: OHHHKAY!
Wade: Ha ha
[Bob laughing]
[explosion]
M: ...oh okay
M: [giggling]
J: Lead 'em on, Wade!
[Wade screaming]
M: Wade--stay in there, Wade! Stay in there, Wade!
M: [laughing] Stay in there Waade!
[all laughing]
[explosion]
J: You just made it!
B: So why don't we just run in and then run out of all these rooms?
J: Yeah.
B: AHHH!
J: F*ck sake!
J: Stupid doors!
B: How do you open these?
W: Go ahead...
W: ...try that strategy out.
M: E!
W: Run- run up
to the middle of each room and run back.
M: No, No, No!
You guys are a bunch of cowards!
M: You walk in and bravely face what you got!
J: Yeah, okay.
M: You deal with the cards that you're dealt with...
M: Uh Oh
W: NO HO HO HO HO!
M: UH
M: Guys?
GUYS--
Mark: OH GOD
[Everyone laughs at Mark]
M: AAAAAAHH!
[Laughter continues]
M: NOOOO!
HELP ME!
MY CARDS SUCK!!
AAAAAAAAAAGGGGGHHHH!!!!
M: Guys, I think it's okay...
Bob: I kind of want to see what's happening...
M: Okay, I'm dead.
B: I kind of want to see what's happening...
M: I'm dead. [chuckling] Alright.
B: [Sarcastic] Aww
I thought you were gonna make it.
J: I CHOOSE THIS ROOM!
M: [HUEHUEHUE]
B: [giggles] I'll just watch from over here...
[Mark and Bob giggling]
J: Hey, the room I chose was good!
J: Yaaaay!
M: Yeah!
M: Not bad!
B: Alright, let's go
He's probably lying, hang on...
W: Can you spectate, Mark?
M: Yeah, I'm spectating you, Wade.
W: Okay.
M: You go in next.
J: Okay, you get to choose where we go, then.
W: Alright, I'm going here!
B: No, Mark gets to-
W: OH NO this is a pink roo-
M: I don't get to choose shit...
W: oh god, well...
B: Have fun, Wade!
M: Oh, that doesn't look good!
W: Wait, is this the exit!?
M: HEEEEEEEY!
B: What?
M: WOOOOAAAH!
J: OK, DANCE, BOY!!
B: Yaaaaay...
M: [In a happy tone] I'm dead-
but I got the most score!
I got the biggest score!!
B:This is true!
W: [chuckling] You were one room off of winning.
J: How does that help?
M: You know what--
J: All bad rooms.
M: Shut up.
I think it's fine.
J: Dude, check out this sick music.
Dooo!
Doo!
M: I can't hear anything.
J: Everyone vote!
Mark: Where, what do we do?
Wade: Soooo-
Bob: How do you vote?
Jack: Your mouse shows up on screen when you wiggle it enough.
Bob: Oh.
Mark: I didn't know what we were voting on.
Jack: If someone dies this time, they get to choose where we go.
Mark: Ok.
Wade: This is a small map, we can do a bigger map.
Mark: We'll do it later.
Mark: I wanna get the feel for it.
Jack: I- I think we're ok for now.
Mark: Alright
Bob: Do you want me to go first this time? I haven't done it yet.
Wade: Go ahead, Bob.
Jack: Yeah. Go.
Mark: Go Bob
Bob: I'm not gonna move.
Jack: Oh, you're both girls now.
Wade: You got a checkmark, Bob, good work!
Mark: Ooh.
Jack: Yeah, you got a good room, Bob.
Mark: Yay!
Bob: I'm a genius.
Mark: Bob, you the best.
Jack: Me and Bob are one for one right now.
Mark: Alright
Bob: Yeah, baby.
Wade: We have 2 Howie Mandels-
Mark: Bob!
Mark: Bob! Oh, you're so good and brave!
Bob: Oh, yeah...
Jack: Ah, you're such...
Jack: It's- it's the bald head.
Bob: Oh, god, oh yeah.
Jack: Get under me, Bo- get over me Bob.
Mark: Oh my god.
Bob: This is the one I choose.
Wade: Mark is the one to go now.
Mark: *giggles* Me?
Jack: Somebody has to pick a room next.
Mark: Alright...
Wade: Yeah, Mark's up.
Mark: Alright, I got this, guys.
Mark: You big bubble-blowing babies. Watch this.
Wade: Watch the green room..
[Jack laughs]
Mark: Aw sh*t. Well
Bob: Ohhhhkaay
Jack: Exact same thing as last time.
Mark: Umm?
[Bob laughs]
Mark: I dunno about this one, guys.
[Bob still laughing]
Bob: I think it's fine.
Bob: I think it's gonna be fine.
Jack: See ya later.
Mark: Guys ke- I feel so lonely in here.
[Jack laughs]
Bob: We're tryna open it back up.
Bob: Hang on, we-
Jack: The red-
Wade: Yeah
Mark: AH, OH GOD!
Jack: On the map may-
Bob: Oh my god!
Wade: Oh.
Mark: The f*ck happened?
Bob: Oh jesus.
Wade: Oh.
Jack: Woah!
Mark: Ohhh. I exploded into pieces.
Bob: Kay.
Jack: Okay!
Wade: So does that mean (its) Jack's turn?
Mark: Uhhhh
Jack: Sure!
Bob: Sure ya.
Mark: Oh geez [giggles]
Jack: Uhhhh.
Jack: This way. I choose this one.
Wade: Alright Jack.
Jack: See ya later, guys.
Jack: I'm off, I'm off to the war.
Bob: Oh, it's yellow, it's yellow..
Wade: OH!!
Wade: Look out Bob!
Mark: Woah
Bob: AH!! AH!!
Jack: Ha HAHH!!
[Mark giggles]
Jack: This game is on MY side.
[Mark laughs]
Jack: I got a check mark.
Wade: Yeah, but we almost got cooked.
Bob: Man, that thing was really pissed at us for not coming in with you.
Mark & Jack: Yeah.
Bob: This time I'm-
Wade: That means it's me?
Jack: Yeah, and then after that Mark gets to choose.
Mark: Guys, I got a good feeling about that door.
Mark: I got a good feeling, Wade.
Mark: That one's a good one.
Wade: I do too.
Mark: Yeah
Wade: What?
Jack: No!
Jack: Demon, demon chainsaw man.
Mark: Nah, it's fine.
Mark: It's fine. He's easy.
Bob: Oh.
B: He laughs.
J: Dude he-he looks like the guy from Daft Punk.
Mark: Ohhhh.
Wade: He's very daft.
Mark: He looks like Genji, with his head.
Jack: He kinda do.
Mark: Ya lil' bit.
Bob: AH!
Bob: He's coming towards me.
Bob: Oh Jesus
Jack: It's motorcycle Genji.
Jack: You- sir?
Jack: Sir, not over there. Agh I'm locked out again.
Wade: Time for you to despawn motorcycle-Genji!
Wade: Yeah, there we go.
Mark: There we go.
Wade: Alright Mark, you get to pick a room ( M: I- ) for one of us.
Mark: *I* get to pick? Oh ok.
Mark: Well, you guys know how good my picking skills are so, umm..
Bob: Yeah yeah yeah.
Wade: So is it Mark's turn? Is Mark making one of us go into a room of his choice?
M: I'm gonna say- I say east
Mark: I say East. East is what I think.
Bob: Alright.
Wade: Who's gonna go in?
Bob: I was gonna volunteer to go. I was letting Mark pick, but I was volunteering to go.
Mark: Oh ok. Bob, I appreciate you, I appreciate you.
Wade: Oh, Bob's volunteering.
Jack: We'll go in a cycle.
[Bob yelps]
Mark: Ah it's demon man.
Jack: The same again? Demon man, really?
B: Hey buddy.
Bob: Hey friend.
Mark: He ain't nothin'.
Jack: He aint shit.
Wade: Alright, c'mon, Bob!
Jack: Dude, I really like the lense flares going on. That's cool.
Mark: Yeah, JJ Abrams in here.
Bob: Will you just despawn already, you motherfucker?
Wade: No, noo...
Jack: Goddammit, door!
Bob: Hey, guys.
Bob: So, Jack picks--
Wade: So, Bob, you get to pick now?
Bob: Yeah, I'll pick again. I'm feelin' lucky man, I'm feelin' it.
Wade: Alright
Mark: Yeah, Bob's got-- Bob got in the way
Bob: I'm going-- I'm stickin' with east (x2), f*ck it.
Mark: Nice. Good move, good move.
Wade: I like it. Dedicated.
Jack: Isn't that north? [chuckles]
Bob: Ok.
Mark: No that's east!
Bob: Uhhh..
Jack: But we just came from this one!
Wade: Did you just throw a shoe? [chuckles]
Mark: Hey! We said no shoes!
Bob: Nooooo.
Bob: I'm totally fine.
Bob: Yeah, I'm the best at this game!
Jack: That naw-
Jack: That doesn't count, that doesn't count.
Bob: Why doesn't that count?
Jack: You threw a shoe, you- you- You disobeyed the rules. Ooh!
Bob: I went inside the room and then I threw a shoe.
Jack: Exit next, right? 'Cause there's pinks on the ground?
Wade: Maybe?
Jack: No? Is that how that works?
Wade: I don't know.
Wade: You're up Jack, so you pick it.
Jack: Hello?
Mark: Uhhhh.
Wade: That's a safe room.
Jack: Ah, balls! Ah, balls!
Mark: Oh no! OH NO!
Jack: Oh no, IT'S THE THING THAT-- AHHHHH!!
Mark: Oh no!
B: Oh no! Oh god no!
Jack: I'M ON FIRE! I'M ON FIRE!!
[Mark laughs]
Bob: Run in circles!
Jack: I don't like it! I'm trying! I'm movin'!
Jack: I'm being cooked. It doesn't matter.
Wade:  You're gonna be fine, Jack!
Jack: It's all over. It's all death. I'm dead. F*ck.
M: That's a lot of screaming goin' on there.
Bob: Ohhh
Mark: Hey look, free shoes!
Jack: Hey, my shoes are green.
Bob: Yeah, can I get those?
Bob: I'd love some shoes.
Jack: Aw, man.
Wade: That, uhh, the cage never goes away.
Bob: Alright, where'ya going, Wade?
Wade: Well, the only other direction we can. (chuckles)
Bob: Spedicey is dead now.
Wade: WOOOOO!!
Jack: That better have been the fucking-
Wade: AHHH!!
[Mark and Jack laugh]
Bob: Oh no!
Wade: AGH!
Mark: Ohhh.
Jack: Oh god.
Bob: Oh my god!
Jack: JESUS!
Mark: OH BOY!
Wade: AHHHH!!
Bob: Holy shit!
Mark: Oh boy!
Jack: So Bob, you have to go back.
Mark: Yeah, Bob, you got the luck here.
Jack: Go back to the orange one.
Mark: You got the luck. You're doing good.
Wade: Oh my god, I'm dead.
Bob: I-I'm pretty sure you died there, buddy.
Wade: Yeah.
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: Alright.
Jack: Well Bob-
Jack: -found two chainsaw dudes so-
Mark: Yeah, keep going, Bob, you got this.
Bob: I-I've got- you know what?
Bob: East really betrayed us as a team, I'm gonna go weast.
Mark: Yeah, I-I agree.
Mark: I agreast
*Jack chuckles*
Bob: I think- I think weast is the way.
Mark: Yeah
Bob & Wade: Pink.
Bob & Mark: Pink's good.
Mark: Pink's good.
Bob: Ah ah ah ah.
Jack: Checkmark?
Bob: Yeah?
Mark: Niiiiccee.
Jack: Yah! Yah!
[Wade laughs]
Mark: [joining Jack] Neeyeah! Yeah!
Jack: 'Got it.
[Mark and Jack laugh]
Bob: Okay, my instinct was to go north,
Bob: so fuck that.
Jack: Nyah
Mark: Yeah, exactly.
[Wade chuckles]
Bob: So wait, what do-- what do you guys pick?
Bob: We can still rotate who picks.
Mark: No, no you got this buddy, it's all you.
Bob: I can't take all the glory.
Wade: Yeah.
Jac: We believe in ya, Howie!
Mark: Although I think that's next to the one we started
Bob: Oh.
Mark: at so I doubt that's going to be the exit.
Jack: Yeah, bold choice!
Wade: Yeah, it could be. Green is good, maybe.
Jack: Bold choice!
Jack: Now you have to go through it.
Bob: I'm not gonna-
Mark: Yeah, nah, yeah, nah.
Jack: No, stop bein' a pussy!
Mark: No, no, no, Bob, you be the biggest pussy you wanna be. You-you-you stick with what you do.
B: Ok!
Jack: *laughs* Instant death!
*Wade and Mark laugh*
Jack: C'mon death!
Wade: What color's this one?
Mark: Green!
Bob: Oh shiiiit.
Wade: Green again.
Mark: What do the colors - Ahh, you got boned.
[Bob starts panicking]
Jack: Lasers!
[Bob continues to panic]
Mark: That don't seem good.
Jack: What is it?
All: OHHH!!
Jack: Oh no, it's like Resident Evil!
Mark: It's Resid-  Yeah! Resident Evil!
Bob: Wait, yeah Resident Evil.
Bob: How did she do that? Hang on, hang on.
Mark: Jump! Jump up on the ceiling!
Bob: Hang on, I got this, I can do this.
[Mark, Jack & Wade tell Bob to jump]
J: Jump through! Jump, no, barrel-roll!
Bob: Ohh.
Jack: Tuck your knees!
Bob: What's the barrel-roll button?
Mark, Bob, & Wade: Ohh.
Jack: Oh no.
Jack: That is not how physics works.
[Mark laughs]
Jack: Hey!
Mark: Well-
Jack: I vote again.
Mark: Again?
Jack: Restart.
Bob: Yeah, what are we voting for? Restart?
Mark: Alright, okay.
Jack: Yeah, no fucking shoes this time, Bob.
Mark: Yeah.
*Wade laughs*
Bob: I missed the- I missed the discussion where we said we weren't going to do shoes.
Mark: *laughs*
I thought we were all just being cool.
Mark: Yeah, no shoes guys.
Wade: Alright, here, just to prove my loyalty.
Mark: Yeah, take your shoes off, put 'em in the corner.
Jack: Ev-Everyone put your shoe in the pile.
[Mark laughs]
Bob: No one is going to pile up their shoes in the middle?
Mark: The middle?
Jack: Oh, you can actually throw both shoes? Oh.
Mark & Bob: Yeah.
Jack: I didn't know that.
Bob: Oh, is this the shoe corner?
Mark: Oh sorry, shoe corner?
Bob: Shoe- shoe corner over there.
Wade: Shoe corner.
Jack: Aw, that's so cute.
Mark: Nice.
Bob: It's like a bunch of little kids are having a sleepover.
Jack: They look like the shoes from-
Mark: Awww!
Jack: They look like the shoes from Back to the Future.
Bob: And then in the morning we're all gonna come upstairs and it's gonna be like "Uhh, which one of these is mine? Uhhh"
Jack: Okay, cool, pickin' a room.
Mark: Alright, go for it.
Wade: Jack's just on a mission.
Bob: We all wear the same-
Bob: We all wear the same shoes.
Mark: Green, huh? Mmmm
Jack: No- no grids, no grids.
Mark: No foolsies!
*Jack sings*
Bob: Checkmark!
Mark: Alright, nice.
Wade: Woohoo!
Bob: Alright, I will go next.
Mark: Alright, Bob, you got this.
Bob: I'm on a real roll here right now-
Bob: So I'm gonna go downtown to south town.
Mark: And Bob-
Jack: Downtown.
Wade: I like it.
Mark: I- uhh
Mark: I like your red hair. Bob-
Wade: I like the way you think.
Jack: You got it.
Bob: This downtown Bob to- oh shhhhhit.
Mark: Oh no, all over again.
J: *laughs* The grid is always bad.
J: The same again.
M: Ohhhh nooo!!
W: Goodbye, Bob.
*Wade laughs*
M: NOOOO!!
J: Aww.
B: Could you guys- could you guys give me a sh-
B: Could you have- do you have any shoes? Could you- do you have any- do you guys
*Mark, Wade & Jack laugh*
B: Can you hand through a bottle of water? Can you hand me anything?
J: Bye Bob. Bye.
W: See ya, Bob.
B: You guys help me out, you guys got anything- Okay.
*Mark, Jack & Wade laugh*
J: You just fucking explode!
M: Yeah.
W: Alright.
W: I'm gonna go over here.
M: Alright, Wade.
B: I just wanted you to enjoy my dead body spray.
W: Oh yellow- yellow is for this fine fellow. So-
M: Probably good, yeah, get over there.
J: Is-is that death?
M: Looks good to me.
M: Looks good to me, looks good to me.
W: No, every- everything is fine.
M: It's a checkmark- goddammit this fucking door.
B: checkmaaaark.
J: Ding ding.
M: This door shouldn't close so soon.
W: Woo hoo!
B: The door's timed to annoy you if you're a bitch and you don't go in at the first try.
J: Yeah, that's....stupid.
*Mark laughs*
M: Alright I got this one.
M: Alright, so south is obviously a death, so north must be the right way to go.
W: Alright, Mark, yeah, north-
W: That's the exit.
B: Yeah south is- south is not the way.
M: Yeah, thanks. Thanks.
M: Ah yeah this looks good, guys. Ooo, what's this? It's a black hole.
B: This is definitely good. That's what you want.
*everyone laughs*
J: You just crumbled! That was awesome!
*M, B, & W continue laughing*
*more laughing*
B: *imitating Mark* Ooo, what's this?
W: It's a black hole.
J: Crunch!
M: I honestly- it was glowing. It looked nice. Wait, who the fuck is that?
J: Oh god, what the f-
B: Woah, what, what?
W: Wait.
W: It's another Howie.
M: What the fuck?
M: What? What?
J: It's Gollum? Beginner Scout.
B: The fuck?
M: Alrighty then.
J: Can you, like-
J: Go through doors for us?
M: I don't know.
M: The hell.
B: Why is he doing that and what the hell?
J: Sir?
M: What the heck.
B: Sir or madam?
M: He's out of shoes.
J: I'm- I'm really uncomfortable.
M: Yeah, that's weird.
B: Alright, Wade's up.
J: It's a Beginner Scout though.
W: I feel like we need to go- uh, weast.
M: Of course.
J: Dude, I've- I've only had one bad choice so far.
M: Yeah, me, m-
W: Woo...!
M: -me too, man.
W: ...OOHH
J: Welp, I guess I'm alone.
B: This is probably- this is probably fine. it's fine.
W: Tell my shoes I love them.
J: But you can-you can dodge! You can dodge! Try it.
M: Yeah, you can dodge this.
J: I don't know what's happening. I can't see it anymore.
M: Wait, don't get closer to it.
M: Get in the corner or something, I don't know.
J: Does it extend?
M: OHH never mind.
J: Ooooohhhhh
[Mark laughs]
W: That's a tesla coil.
[Mark keeps laughing]
B: Wade, why didn't you dodge it, man.
J: Wait woow
[Mark keeps laughing]
B: Wade, why didn't you dodge it, man.
M: Yeah, why didn't you dodge it?
B: Hey, wait, Jack, open that door- open that door that the Scout's looking at and let him go in there.
B: Oh that's already checked off though.
J: But we just came from there.
M: Yeah, we already did there.
B: What the hell.
J: Yeah, and I can't, like, click on him or anything.
B: Well that's not cool.
M: I think he's just there to creep you out.
B: That's weird.
W: Yeah
J: What's a Beginner Scout achievement? -unlocked.
B: Is he humming?
J: Yeah.
M: Huh.
B: Is he humming?!
W: I think Beginner Scout achievement means that you've scouted a certain number of rooms.
*Jack hums*
M: Ohhhhh okay.
*Jack still humming*
B: Alright well, you've only- you've only got one pathway.
J: He's just singing to himself.
M: Wade, you've got this. What are the odds- err sorry, Jack, what are the odds it's gonna be bad?
B: We've only got one pathway, friend.
J: [dramatically breathes] Into manhood.
B: Forward. There's probably a chainsaw demon, guys.
M: *starts singing the Jurassic park theme song*
B: Oh my god, a checkmark.
J: Dude, what is with my luck?
M: Nice.
all: Uh oh.
M: That- okay
W: Go for the door, Jack! Go for the door!
B: Run away! Run away! Hurry, it's a trap!
J: I'M FUCKING TRYING! SHUT UP! LEAVE ME ALONE!
M: OHH it's dodgeable. Oh, hey.
M: Hey, friend.
J: Ummmmm.
J: I don't like these ones.
M: Wow, okay.
B: Oh my god, what the hell.
W: I think the red- red numbers sound bad.
M: Alrighty.
J: Okay. Proobably.
W: Red means all three rooms are instant death,
B: HAHaaHa
W: ...If I had to guess.
J: Wait, let's see what colors are in the rooms.
B: Yeah, no, do some research. I like it. I like it.
W: Yellow.
J & W: Blue!
B: Oh, blue. Blue is good.
M: Both- Oh, it's blue.
M: Nope, blue is not good. Guys, blue is not good.
*Wade laughs*
B: Oh.
J: Oh my god.
J: I don't want cookies! I DON'T WANT OREOS! AHHHH HEELP!
*Bob and Wade laugh*
M: I think you can make it. You're gonna be fine. Just believe.
J: HOOOW?! Save me! Awww.
Wade: Bye, Jack.
*Jack crying into microphone*
B: Aw, you almost made it, buddy.
M: Well, that didn't work out.
W: Good work, everyone.
B: Yeah, we got so close.
M: *laughs* What-
J: Look at that score. *laughs*
M: What other uh- what other game modes do they have?
W: Uh, there's competitive where we're competing with one another. I've never done that.
M: Oh, sure.
W: Uh, you want to go back to the lobby?
M: Maybe.
B: Yeah.
B: Yeah
J: Cast a vote, kick player: Wade.
*Jack & Mark laugh*
J: F1 to vote yes
W: Hey!
M: I gotcha, I got your back. I like this. I like this. This is good.
W: What? No!
*Bob laughs*
J: Thanks, thanks. *laughs*
M: I feel good about this.
*Bob continues laughing*
W: Oh, I voted yes, too.
*M, J, & B laugh*
B: -do a competition.
M: Yeah, competition.
W: Competition. Teams are at opposite ends, exit's in the middle of the map.
M: Hell yeah.
B: Yes
M: Hell yeah
W: For teams ok
M: It's 2v 2-
W: Teams, okay. 31 by 3, we can use shoes, we're on hard, no time limits.
M: -Let's make it the smaller one of those. Smaller one with shoes. I- I-
B: So we might actually succeed.
M: Yeah, so there's a chance. Yeah.
W: Okay, 21 by 3.
W: Alright, server's up.
W: Oh, we get to pick what team we're on. I'm on team 1.
M: I'll be on your team, Wade. I got you.
W: Alright.
Jack: But it just auto-teamed us.
B: It's me and Spedicey.
M: Nah, I changed it.
J: Oh, okay.
M: Alright.
J: Let's fucking do it, Bobby Boy.
M: I got it.
B: Let's do this shit, Spedicey.
M: Alright, Wade, we got this.
B: Oh hey, friend.
J: Hey!
W: I'm going straight for the middle
M: Alright, you do that.
M: WOOOAAH!!
W: WHAT IS THAT?!?!
M: OH MY GOD!!
B: Uhhhh
W: WHAHAHAT?!
M: The fuck is that?
J: Lu-
J: Lu- Let's
J: Let's throw some shoes
W: I DON'T KNOW
Mark: You guys have no idea what we're seeing right now.
J: OH, JESUS!!
J: Run, Bob, run!
B: Go into the next room! Go into the next room! Go to the next room!
M: Ohhh.
J: We're good, we're good.
J: Ah, he blew up your shoes!
M: Did you guys-
M: Guys, did you guys just see a glowing skeleton walk outta your room?
J: *quietly* Your shoe- get your shoe back!
J: No, we had a dude like the chainsaw guy run at us.
M: Doh, we had a glowing skeleton.
B: *quietly* Oh, Jesus Christ.
B: Uh, uh a-a demon douchebag came into our room and then exploded.
J: Can you press E-
J: To pick this up, Bob?
W: Well.
B: I cannot.
M: Uhhh.
J: It says "Press E to pick up" on my screen.
B: Oh oh okay, yeah.
M: I-Imma shoe-
M: Imma shoe it
J: Okay.
J: Tha- BOB NO! Come back!
M: I think we're good.
M: Goddamn these doors!
J: Wait, how does that room count as a check mark?
W: Yeah, these doors close way too fast.
M: Ok, I think it's good.
M: I think it's good, Bob, I think it's good.
B: Alight, where are we going friend?
W: Alright.
M: Oh, Wade.
W: I mean, I guess we might as well keep moving this way.
W: Oh wait, what?
M: Oh, hey! Ok, that's weird.
W: Oh, chainsaw.
M: Ok. That's bizarre.
W: Chainsaw behind us.
J: Throwin' a shoe.
W: Look out behind ya!
M: Alright. I got it.
J: I don't think there's anything in there, Bob.
M: These shoes don't do do shit, dude!
B: *quietly* Uhhhhh.
J: Yeah, what the fuck?
M: Oh no, wait, it did. It just took a delay.
M: Wooo.
J: Oh god! OH GOD!
All: WOOOOOAH!!
B: Door! DOOR! DOOR! *Laughs*
M: Good shoe! Good shoe! Good-
M: Shoe!
J: Jesus Christ!
B: God! Jeez!
*Bob laughs*
M: Good shoe! Good shoe, Wade!
B: Oh my god! The shoes don't help at all...
M: Yeah, the shoes help! You-u don't know that they don't help.
M: They might help.
J: They might help now.
M: Ohhh, that's right. Ok.
B: I did- I just think it was funny when we walked in to-
B: -that room, I got
M: Which way do you think?
M: North? I'll go north.
B: -the achievement for finding 5 traps
B: -and I was like, "Ah."
J: Ugh.
W: I'll- I'll trust you on that one.
B: "Traps, you say?"
M: Alright, I got this. *grunts*
W: Somehow Jack and Bob got 10 times louder, like-
M: Wooah.
W: Whenever you-
J: Yeah, we just got a lot more ram- rambunctious.
M: Ohhhh.
M: Ok, so-
J: I don't know what that did. I think they-
B: I think- I think-
J: -I think that room ate my shoe.
W: I think it'll eventually end.
M: Will it? I mean, it looks like there's paths to run around it.
B: I think we're good.
W: Well, I think the red traps on the- on the map mean-
J: You found 5 traps. Get out. Get out. Get out. Get out.
W: -that they are permanent, whereas these are-
B: Ah! Ah! Ah!
W: -like-
W: Well I don't know, we can just try going around it.
M: I will try. Oh shit.
J: I just got an achievement-  -you found 5-
M: Goddammit.
J: -traps. *laughs*
J: But I also got one for Scout.
M: Yeah, see what's down there, Wade.
B: We didn't get check marks, so- ohhhhhh, hey lasers.
J: Oh. We just dodged lasers, bro.
W: Oh.
B: Bro, we dodged the sh*t out of those lasers.
J: Those are some super slow lasers.
*Jack laughs*
M: Ok. Alright. Should I not go for my shoe here?
W: You can try but-
M: Imma- I got it. Ok, it worked.
J: These shoes do f*ckin' nothing.
B: Good job, team mate.
M: Oo, whoops.
M: I'm, uhh.
B: It's all about the sprinting in-
W: Oh.
B:  -frantically and-
W: I'll open the door.
B: -getting the f*ck out.
M: Ughh, hurry, hurry, hurry, hurry-
M: -hurry, hurry. Woouh. Ok.
J: Ok. I- I- I like our- -method.
M: Wohkay.
B: Let me-
B: Let me try my shoe.
W: Oh, come on. Don't-
J: Bob, get ou- move, move, move, move!
*Bob spouts gibberish in fear*
J: Jesus!! What is that?
*Bob laughs*
M: Jeez.
B: It's like a...  -or something. I don't know.
J: Is tha- Is that ice?
B: Goddammit.
J: *laughing* There's 2-
J: -kinds of people: ice and acid.
M: Wade, they-
M: They seem to be flailing like losers-
M: While we are the top of the food chain here.
W: Yeah, we're doin' very well over here.
J: Well, we're not dead.
*Mark blows raspberry*
B: Oh no! Sweet Jesus!
J: Oh, lasers! Get out, get out, get out!!
J: Oh, lasers! Get out, get out, get out!
M: Alright.
J: It was TWO traps!!
B: Double trap is such a bitch move!
*Mark grunts as he throws his shoe*
W: Got it. Oh, you got it.
J: Douche move.
B: How many-
M: How many do we have to-
M: It's gooood. Ah, cool.
B: get through to get to the middle?
W: Imma gonna go back... this way.
M: North? Yeah. Get back on the main track.
W: Yeah.
M: Yeah.
J: I- If- Are we making progress towards anything?
*Wade grunts strangely as he throws his shoe*
J: We probably should be learning how to play the game and all the things.
M: Nice. Nice. Nice, nice.
M: So long as it doesn't laser us down- Woooah.
W: Oh, oh, we gotta moooove!
M: Woa, woah, what was that? Here, here, in here.
M: Ohh no, I just walked in! Wade, I'm sorry!! Wade!!
J: Oh, Bob. Oh, Bob.
W: Nooooooo!!
M: Waaaaade!!
B: Oh no!
B: Oh god, it's an exploding douchebag. Open the door, openthedoor, openthedoor,openthedoor,openthedoor!
M: Waaade! Ahhhh!!
B: Ah ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
M : Wade, tell- Wade, win for us.
M: Wade, you have to carry on, you have to win... aAHHH!!
W: I'll do- I'll do my best. Awww!
J: Oh, you've 2 shoes now.
B: Dude!
J: Ok, I think we need to- awww, someone died on the other team.
M: Yeah,
M: Whatever, I- it was a heroic sacrifice.
B: *sarcastic* Oh nooo, someone is dead. Nooo.
M: It was a- It was a heroic sacrifice-
J: Bob, I picked a different door.
M: It was a heroic sacrifice, ok?
J: What was that? What was that? I heard- Oh there's a blade in the middle. Don't go in there.
W: Aha.
W: Ok.
*Jack laughs*
B: I'll trigger it again and see what else we got.
M: Wade, you gotta keep movin'. We don't have a lot of time.
J: Ok. Ok. We got this.
B: Let me go for a quick lap-around.
J: I think it's just that. Oh wait-
M: You're good. You're good, Wade, you're good. You're good. You're good, Wade.
B: Oh oh oh,
M: Wade, you're good.
W: Woo!
B: Oh, I'm good. I'm good.
M: Keep goin'. Keep goin', Wade. You got this.
I'm gonna go back north again 'cuz
B: Oh, that sucks you in!! AHH!!
J: I fuckin' told you, Bob!!!
B: I never stopped moving. It just caught me somehow.
M: HA HA! HA HA!
J: Goddammit! Ok, now it's a race against time.
W: Ok.
J: Oh god, I can't fuckin' run against it.
W: Stupid doors!
B: Oh no!
J: WHAT?!
B: Oh, see? See? That was bullshit.
M: Ha ha. Ha ha. HA HA HA!
M: Wade, it's all you. It's all you, baby.
W: Am I the last one alive?
J: Yeah.
M: You got it. The whole way. Go for it.
W: Why's this?
J: Aww, man. I'm sorry, Bob.
W: This doesn't look like such a good room.
M: No, go for it.
B: I-I-I
W: ahh stupid doors
M: If you toss the shoe in it'll either immediately trigger the con-whoa
B: i fucking did my best
J: I believe you
M: Oh thats weird
M: aww your shoe got destroyed
W: my shoe just exploded on those icicles
M: Why'd you throw it there?
W: Well cause I was throwing it cause it didnt go off before
M: No if you throw it in your only checking for the laser
M: Like wall so that you can't get out
L: Oh No
M:Thats the only thing alright you gotta go for it
M: Alright you got it
M: Keep running GO GO GO keep running!
M: NO NOT BACK!! Jesus Wade!!!
W: I'll go back
M: Be BRAVE!  J: Wade use your balls
B: Wade, it doesn't turn off
W: (determined) I'm gonna go through it.
M: Yeah, just go around it. It-d-I-I went to this it's fine, you're good.
W: Yeah
M: See now you gotta wait for TEN YEARS for this to go around. (B: This seems fine)
*Jack laughs*
M: Look. You're close to the exit. (B: This seems normal) You're close.
M: You just gotta go towards the middle
M: A FEW more, and you're THERE
M: Just--I think it's just TWO more (J: I feel like I'm right inside your ear right now)
W: This one's gonna be real good
J: Go go go
M: You got this. Yeah go for it you got it.
B: Yeah do it. Awesome job.
W: WOOOOOOO
W: OH!  I DID IT!!
M: No keep going
M: No that's it, that's it! YEEEAAAHH!!!
B: Oh Goddamn
W: I did it!
M: Yaaaaaaayyyyyy
B: Wow
M: HELL yeah
W: Team BumLord!
M: Hell yeah!
B: F*cking bullsh*t
M: Hell yeah
J: I feel like-I feel like we got shafted
B: F*ckin baloney
M: You want a rematch?
W: You guys shafted yourselves!
J: Got shafted by the fan blade, we triggered it and then it-
M: Oh yeah
W: We can do a rematch if you guys are up for it.
M: Yeah, if you guys are.... not a bitch
B: Wade, just because you finally won something doesn't mean you can be snide.
W: Hey! I found the exit the first game too..
J: Yeah, but that was all cooperative, so we ALL won. That's boring.
B: Yeah, pretty much
M: All right, all right Wade..
B: It's all about speed-
J: Hey! We found a Howie
B: -and oh, hey friend. Up, nope! Nope, nope! What is that? What is that? What is that? What is that? What is that?
M: Oh, it's good!
J: What is that? What is that? What is that? Get out, get out!
J: Oh, it's the goo! I thought it was the exit, 'cause it was green!
M: Oh, we're fine!
B: I know! I was like, "Yay, the exit! F*ck this room!"
M: There's a guy in here. There's a dude in here.
W: Oh! Yay!
M: Alright, your turn
W: I don't think that that always implies that we're safe, though. Maybe it does.
J: I don't know if that stops.
M: Nah, it's fine... probably.
J: Green?
W: Alright, WABEESH! Oh.
M: Whoops, uh oh. Okay, good thing, good thing that's okay.
J: Oh god, oh god. You s-you scared me. Okay, so, we don't get trapped in here.
J: MOOOVE!
B: Oh sh*t!
B: Oh f*ck! F*ck! F*ck! F*ck! F*ck!
B: Door me! Door me! Door me!
M: Alright, y-you shoe, you shoe. You shoe next.
J: I can't f*cking door you!
M: Shoe next. Whoa!
W: Oh, oh whoa were those icicles?
B: I'm good, I'm good, I'm good, I'm good.
J: Why'd you rush in?!
W: Got it.
B: 'Cause I thought it wasn't gonna do anything.
M: Alright, we're good.
J: No the shoe just means that you don't get the f*ckin blocked in room. It doesn't mean that you're safe.
W: Arright.
B: Aight.
M: Ooh! Okay there's- okay.
W: Oh that's a- a one of those.
M: Yeah, lemme grab my shoe!
J: HUAAAH!
J: Yeah, see?
W: Oh, get out, yeah- get out of th- that one's quick!
M: Yeah, okay. We can go... that'll go down eventually but we can still try the other ones.
B: Bye shoe.
J: Bye shoe
B: We're gonna go back, huh?
J: I-I can't enter.
W: *strange mating growl*
J: Oh right yeah.
B: Those are- those are the edge of the map, so we're gonna go this way?
W: Okay
M: Okay, you're good (2x). Ohh, look out.
M: Okay, g- move, move, move. Aright, here we go.
W: Woohohohohohohoho
J: Okay, throw a shoe!
M: Shoop! Wookay, that's a bad one okay.
W: Oh, oh your shoe's still here though!
B: Oh, oh, oh. To the left, demon demon demon.
J: Demon, demon, demon man.
W: Oh, never mind, it's gone.
M: Yeah, yeah, it's probably gone.
J: Okay, we're good, let's just sit out here!
J: Have some tea.
B: Yeah, let's just hang out. He'll despawn eventually.
M: Alright Wade, yeah we got this okay!
B: Hey, buddy!
M: Googity googoo! Your shoe?
J: *making Link sounds*
W: Arright.
J: Nice!
W: Whoa!
M: Go for it.
J: Uhh, Team 2 Bob said, "Yes, look out Smiley!"
M: Okay, we're good. We're good.
W: Okay.
M: Oh that's, noo hey! Yeah it's fine (2x) he's okay.
J: Get your shoe.
W: Oh, there's a chainsaw.
B: Hey I got my shoe back, yay!
J: Okay, we're going this way!
B: oh, can't go that way
J: Okay, I'll use- I'll use- Okay, you use your shoe. you have two
M: Let's go through here. Let's go through here
M: Woah, laser in the middle
W: Okay
J: hup hup
B: What?!?
B: We can't get past!
M: Okay
B: We're blocked in completely
M: OH OH OH
W: Mark, we gotta get out of here!
B: All of these rooms-
M: Get out, get out
J: What?
B: Oh, we have to sneak past this shit
M: Ha, Wade! Over here!
M: Wade, over here! Wade!
B: Hang on, I got- I got
B: Oh, I got it. You gotta go ove- AH
J: Oh, okay
W: WHAT
M:YEAH
J: WHAT
M: YEAH
B: WE WERE COMPLETELY BLOCKED IN! WHAT THE FUCK!
w: Nice work, Mark!
W: Ha ha
M: Hell yeah, haha
B: We had- we had two impassibles and one extremely difficult to get past
W: We literally ran a straight line
B: goddammit
*Mark and Wade laugh*
J: We- Well we tried doing that but all the rooms had traps couldn't be passed in them
M: Well is that-
J: And then we had edge of map everywhere else
*Wade laughing*
J: It was bullshit
M: Is that our fault?
M: Hmm? Is that our problem?
W: Oh my goodness
B: Seems like it
J: oohhhh
W: Do you want to do a tough one where we have shoes or do you just want to do a quick one?
B: No, but I think we should just do one winner, Wade
W: One winner?
B: That we work together as a group but we're fighting to get to the end
W: Okay
M Yeah, that sounds good
B: I think that's interesting
W: One winner
W: Alright, room is created. Let's do it!
W: Only one!
J: See, this fucking fan blade
M: ooohhhh
J: stupid loading screen fan blade
M: Oh wait! The colors- ah shit goddammit
J: Piss me off
J: yeah, how do we-
M: It just gave a description then it went away too quick
B: I wanna go this way
M: alright Bob
W: Oh yeah? Well I'm gonna go this way
M: Wait
W: I hope you enjoy that way
J: Well, that way's bad
B: well, I'm not going that way
W: And this way is just fine
M: Nice way. Nice way, Wade.
B: You guys can go first, this is fine
M: I'm gonna go this way
B: Oh, its a checkmark
M: Ima go this way
M: Welp, ah, it's just that guy?
J: No, its a demon
M: Psshh, nothing
W: Yeah, we're not scared of him
M: Woah, he's fol- woah woah woah
W: AHHH ITS THE DEMON
*Bob laughs*
J: Its the runny- it's the runny explody one
M: Woah hey
W: He drops a shoe so if you lose a shoe you can come back here and get this
M: Nice
B: Oh, let me check this shit out
M: Uh, guys?
W: Oh wait, didn't one of you guys lose a sh- oh wait, what?
*Mark and Jack laugh*
B: wwwwhhhhhhaaaaatttttt
*Mark and Jack continue laughing*
B: Wwwhhhaattt
J: And that counts as us all dying then
*Mark continues laughing*
B: goddammit
*Mark still continues to laugh*
M: I'm sorry
B: Geez
M: Wait, let's redo that one
B: How the fuck?
M: I don't know!
J: I didn't even get a score
M: I'm sorry
*Wade and Bob laugh*
M: I'm just so good
J: so good at winning the game
B: Goddamn
M: so good
W: I thought we were just a good team but it turns out Mark just like knows here the exit is
*Bob laughs*
*Mark and Bob laugh*
W: He's like a bloodhound
B: Alright, everyone just go in every direction. Fuck it
M: Alright, fine then screw you
J: Oh, I found a Howie
J: OH, fan blade fan blade fan blade
M: Okay, well that one didn't work
B: Oh I found a demon motherfucker
J: Oh I'm trapped. I'm dead
M:What? Why didn't you throw your shoe?
J: Because I had to get away from the fan blade that was sucking me in
M: Ooooohhhh, I got it
J: ooohhhhh why me?
J: oh nooooooo
J: NOOOOOOOOO I'm dead
M: oh god this might be bad for me
M: okay
W: ha ha
J: Okay
W: Everything's fine on mi- OOHHH
M: Woah
B: Oooohoho my go- OH SHIT OH GEEZ
W: Was that a-
butts
J: hahaha fire Bob
M: Well
B: God... geez
W: Well, that's a bad room
J: Mark has no shoes left
M: um
M: yeah, I got no shoes
*Bob laughs*
*Bob continues to laugh*
M: I'm just here walking on my tootsies here
B: I think I had one
J: yeah, Bob and Wade have one shoe
B: I had one shoe left
M: Ooo, I picked up a shoe I think
B: Oh I got a shoe OH NO OH GOTTA GO SEE YA
W: Ah ha
M: Ah ha I got a shoe
W: This is the way
W: FORWARD! oh no
B: Hey Mark
M: Oh hi, how are you?
B: I'm good. Do you want to see what's in this room? Its super fun
W: Well at least I got my shoe back
M: Oh, nice
W: Oh screw this, I'm going this way. No one's going west.
M: Nice
B: I don't think it's possible to get past that
B: Oh
W: Oh no
M: It'll stop, it'll stop it'll stop it'll stop
J: It got close Wade
W: I know, oh god. Well, now I'm screwed
J: You almost got trapped
J: Yeah, you have no shoes left
M: Uh, Bob I'm gonna go this way
J: Hey, you found a Howie
M: Bob I'm gonna go this way
M: You- you bore me
B: I'm on a winning- I'm on a winning path, Mark
M: Yeah, whatever
*Jack laughs*
B: You go whatever way you want, I'm on a winning path
M: You're going to the edge of the map, you goof
W: Green is gooOOOOD
M: OH hey, hey buddy. okay
J: You're fine Wade, you're fine
W: I'm going this way
W: This is the exit route
M: Oh god
J: Who's gonna win?
W: NO
M: fan is suck
W: IT'S NOT THE EXIT! IT'S NOT THE EXIT!
M: Ooooh boy, okay
J: Wade's dead
J: Its between Mark and Bob
M: I- I
M: That fan sucks
W: NOOOOO
B: Fuck fuck
J: Okay, its all Bob
M: Alright Bob
W: I feel happy
B: Aw fuck
M: Oh hi Bob. BOB what- what happened to your winning streak?
W: I feel happy
B: What happened to my what?
M: What happened to you- oh that was Wade
M: Okay, sorry
J: You're good, Bob, go
M: You're good go
W: Oh Bob still has two shoes?
M: Bob get your other shoe back. You dropped your other shoe.
B: Yeah, I have both my shoes
J: You didn't- you don't have the other shoe
M: Good job. Bob
J: I believe in you, Bob
*All cheering*
B: I did it! I did it! I did it!
W: Wow
M: OH
B: I did it! I did it!
B: I'm the best
B: You all suck
M: Bob was on a winning streak
B: Yeah
J: Hey, I was on your team for a while
*Mark laughs*
B: Yeah and we got absolutely destroyed
J: We did, we did
[Bob laughs]
B: We were a horrible team
B: I don't know if it was you or me but one of us was really dragging it down
Wade: I have a score of nine
J: You found it in G4
Jack - That's it, that's the end